>>Presenter: Today our guest is award winning
photographer Catherine Hall.
>>audience member: Woo hoo!
>>Presenter: We're gonna be recording this
presentation and it's gonna be posted on the
@Google YouTube channel.
So when we get to the Q&A section there's
a microphone on the right and make use of
that so we can get that on the recording.
>>audience member whispering: I have some
questions.
>>Presenter: Now about Catherine; Catherine
has lots of accomplishments to her credit.
She's a photographer, instructor, mentor,
she has her own weekly photography show and
many, many more accolades.
I was fortunate enough to meet Catherine about
nine months ago.
She was hosting a photo op in San Francisco.
And what really impressed me about Catherine
the first time I met her was her dedication
to make sure that everybody walked away with
a, having experienced something new, having
learned something new from this experience.
So without further ado, it's my pleasure to
introduce you, Catherine Hall.
[Applause]
>>Catherine Hall: Thanks Ricardo and I'm so
honored to be here.
Thank you guys all for coming and filling
up the beautiful colored chairs.
So I'm gonna play a little slideshow first
and then I'll go right into the presentation
and then we'll do questions and answers at
the end.
If anyone has a burning question while I'm
talking feel free to raise your hand.
[Chiming noise]
[Applause]
>>Catherine Hall: What am I gonna teach people
from Google?
The day I started thinking about it and I
think, I'm a professional photographer but
I want you to understand that there is not
a disconnect between you and I.
What I mean by that is every single photograph
that you just saw was a self created project.
It was not a job, it was not a client.
I might have sold the images later, they may
have gotten published or won awards but they
are all things that I went out, I had an idea
and I just pursued it.
And I thought about photography, what does
photography really about?
If you wanna build a body of work it's really
about creating your own opportunities.
And that's true whether you're an amateur,
an enthusiast, a professional, it's across
the board.
So I thought, that's something I wanna discuss,
that's something I wanna share, is how I,
how important it is to be, if you a will,
an opportunist.
So, "Your daughter will not graduate high
school."
That's what my parents were told when I was
in 5th grade.
When I was in 5th grade, you know those multiple
choice tests that have the A, B, C, D?
Instead of reading the question and selecting
the appropriate answer I would make drawings.
[Laughter]
>>Catherine Hall: So I wasn't doing very well
in 5th grade.
[Laughs]
>>Catherine Hall: So my parents took me to
a learning disability place and tried to figure
out what was going on and they proceeded to
tell my parents that they needed to pull me
out of regular school because I would never
finish high school.
I remember my parents telling me that and
I thought, "I don't wanna leave my friends."
And this is the first time I can remember
someone putting a serious limitation on me
and I wasn't gonna buy it.
So, not only did I finish high school
[Laughs]
>>Catherine Hall: but I finished top of my
class at CalPoly and I think I got like two
B's.
The point of the story is it's interesting
how in life people will put limitations on
you and photography is the same way.
It's really hard to be a professional, it's
really hard to do this, it's really hard to
do that, don't try.
And I found that, don't listen to those people.
[Laughs]
>>Catherine Hall: cause the greatest limitations
are really self imposed and by listening to
others that might not have your best interest
at heart.
So, definition of opportunity; a favorable
juncture or circumstances; a good chance for
advancement or progress, all of these.
Opportunity is a great word.
When you think of opportunity you think, "Yeah,
opportunity it's good."
So wouldn't you think the direct correlation
that an opportunist would have an equally
positive connotation?
"One who takes advantage of any opportunity
to achieve an end, often with no regards to
principles or consequences."
Is the definition of an opportunist.
Thesaurus of this, look at this, the synonyms;
conniving, cunning, deceitful, devious, bully,
cheat, delinquent and my absolute favorite,
devil.
[Laughter]
>>Catherine Hall: And I'm thinking, I've been
calling myself an opportunist for years now.
[Laughs]
>>Catherine Hall: That's horrible.
And I started to think how can two words with
the same origin have such opposite meanings?
How can one be so negative and so positive?
And then I realized what it was; people are
jealous.
When you see people out there creating their
own opportunities, excelling, succeeding,
a lot of people get pissed off.
They say they cheat, they say they're, whatever
it is that they say.
The point of the story is there's a sort of
believe in our culture that you shouldn't
get to where you are by creating your own
opportunities and going on the fast track,
you need to work hard, work hard, work hard,
work hard.
We hear that all the time in our culture and
it's so prevalent.
And yes, there's the work hard, work smart
sort of thing and I think, yes, of course
you have to work hard but you should work
smart, equally smart or more smart.
This is my absolute favorite phrase that I
hear, "You are so lucky."
Do you guys get that ever, "You work at Google,
you're so lucky?"
And I think to myself, okay, yeah I'm sure
luck had its point in this whole thing but
really, am I here today cause I'm lucky?
Or because I wanted to be here and I worked
hard for it and I worked smart and I created
my own opportunities?
"There is no scarcity of opportunity to make
at living at what you love; there's only scarcity
of resolve to make it happen."
This is by Wayne Dyer.
And I really, really believe this.
So I'm gonna share with you guys a couple
stories and this is really applicable, a lot
of them will correlate, actually I just realized
there was a couple photos from an assignment
in the slideshow, but most of them weren't.
But, point of the story is whether you're
doing a commercial shoot or a personal project
it's really relevant to everyone.
I wanna emphasize that again.
So I got hired to do this shoot for, by John
Deere and they decided that there was not
gonna be an art director, a team, they forgo,
they forwent the advertising agency completely
and brought me on as the only person in charge
of the shoot.
So, I arrive and they, of course, had set
up models for me and at least got something
there for when I arrived.
I showed up and do not trust people that are
not the photographers or are not the ad agencies
to get you models.
[Laughs]
>>Catherine Hall: Or locations for that matter.
So I got there and realized that early on
that what they had given me was not, the content
they gave me was not gonna allow me to produce
work that I felt proud of.
So we started at 4 a.m., I show up models
aren't good, locations aren't good, long shoot
day, 3, 4 o'clock in the afternoon we're finishing
and I'm thinking 12 hours later I do not like
any of these images.
The easy out would be, "You know what, they
set it up, they decided not to hire an ad
agency and here we are today."
[Coughing]
>>Catherine Hall: But that's not me.
So we're driving away and I'm thinking to
myself, "What am I gonna do?"
And I turned to my assistant and I say, "We're
have to, we're just getting started.
We need to find something else."
So the campaign was, just like Harley Davidson,
John Deere wanted to make it more about lifestyle
than product and that's why they just brought
me in and they didn't bring in an advertising
team is because they really wanted to get
the real life of John Deere.
So I figured, I'm gonna drive around and I'm
gonna find people that use John Deere.
So that's what I did.
And I found this man and that's his home.
And I walked up to his door cause I saw he
had john Deere equipment everywhere and I
thought this would be perfect.
So I walked up to his door, I knocked on it
and I said, "Hey, I'm doing this assignment
for John Deere, is there any way I could shoot
you this afternoon when the light gets nice?"
"Oh, okay, sure."
"Alright, do you have any family members?"
[Laughter]
>>Catherine Hall: Classic Mennonites.
[Laughs]
>>Catherine Hall: Lots of family.
And it was interesting because I asked him
if he had family members, he said, "Yes" I
said, "Can you please have them all come back?
" And this is just some random girl; he doesn't
know me from anyone, walking to his door saying,
"Can you bring your family over so we can
do a photo shoot?"
I show up and they're all, you know, dressed
in their best, right?
And they're so excited to be in this photo
shoot.
So I photographed their family and this was
so exhilarating, this is, I knew when I was
getting it this was what it was like.
This is what John Deere life is like.
So the results from this were that these were
actually the images that they chose to use.
And these images secured me as a, they're
still my client today.
Had I not gone out and done this there's no
way the other images would have passed.
They would have gone back to the theory of
having an ad agency and doing it that way.
So the lesson behind it is really not being
limited by your resources.
Alright, so, I love to travel, who out there
likes travel photography?
A lot, yeah that's a popular one.
That's how I got started, just so you guys
know.
I just would go on trips and take my camera
and take a bunch of photos.
And during one of these excursions I was in
Vietnam and I had this whole plan.
I found out about this little village at the
top of this mountain I thought, "Oh, this
is gonna be such a great experience."
I'd heard of a couple people going to it before
so it was a little bit known but still there
wasn't a ton of Westerners up there and I
thought, "Wow, what an authentic cool thing.
I'm gonna pack a backpack, I'm gonna hike
up there, spend the night and photograph this
village."
Very, very, very excited.
So I'm walking along with my little backpack,
all happy, going to the place and then I come
along this most beautiful girl.
I think, "Oh, I'm just gonna follow this girl."
So I'm following her thinking she's gonna
walk up to the village I'm going to and I'll
get some photographs of her along the way
and it's gonna be fantastic.
So we're walking along and at the base of
the mountain it becomes a split.
Whoa.
[Laughter]
>>Catherine Hall: At the base of the mountain
it becomes a split and we're going left, right?
Except for she goes right and then there's
that moment of plans?
Girl?
Plans?
So I follow my intuition and I follow the
girl.
We walked 4 hours.
This is how far she walks home from school,
4 hours.
You see her little jelly shoes?
We were walking through rice fields with snakes.
This is such a cultural, incredible experience
to see her life.
I'm sorry I don't have a bigger one but this
is their family and this is why she walked
me and brought me to this home.
So much more authentic than a village people
knew about, right?
And I spent the night.
I stayed with them in their home.
Can't speak a word of language, doesn't matter.
And this is what I was exposed to.
I remember walking home the next day and it
started raining and I pulled out my trusty
poncho which, by the way, I totally recommend
when you're shooting, always have a poncho.
Pulled out my trusty poncho put it over m
backpack with my camera, walking and the rain
was pouring over me and I was thinking to
myself, "This is the most amazing day of my
life.
This is the most amazing experience."
So the lesson from this is don't let plan
for possible, keep that in mind possible,
future opportunities make you miss the ones
right in front of you.
It's really easy to have a plan and be really
excited about your plan and be blindsided
to everything else around you.
So if you do have those intuitive hits, photography
is all about intuition, if you have an intuitive
hit while you are shooting, listen to it.
Appalachia, so I had spent several hours with
this family building this beautiful rapport
and I photograph people that's what it's all
about, building a rapport.
I had access to their home, to their backyard,
their family, their kids, I'm working working
working and I'm just not getting anything
but I'm stubborn.
I'm not gonna leave until I get something.
And then I look up and across in the neighbor's
yard I see this girl.
And I think, "Hum, I could be stubborn and
I could stay working with this family I've
invested so much, or I'm getting out of here
right now and going to photograph this girl."
So I went with option B and I knocked on the
door, asked her mom, she hesitantly let me
in the house and into the backyard.
Hesitantly, she told me I could take one photo.
[Coughing]
>>Catherine Hall: And it wasn't like, "Okay,
sure I'll take one photo."
Click, click, click.
It was like, "You can take one photo and I'm
standing right next to you watching me."
So she let me slide with two.
[Laughter]
>>Catherine Hall: But this is what I got.
>>Catherine Hall: So the phrase, don't beat
a dead horse.
If you're photographing something and it's
just not working, I mean you guys are at Google
so I imagine you had a lot of drive and some
of you are probably stubborn like I am, don't
allow your drive and stubbornness to miss
other things that might be around you.
If something's not working photographically
it's okay to let it go and move on to the
next opportunity.
So, Adobe Lightroom Adventure in Tasmania.
This was really exciting, in 2008 Adobe sent
17 of, what they say, are the world's best
photographers to Tasmania to beta test Lightroom
2.
So they sent me along and I was by far the
youngest one.
I was so nervous.
To add insult to injury, I had been, I had
a job already preserved so I had to show up
a week later than everyone else.
So I have all these icons that have already
been there a week, gathering all these wonderful
images, I'm competitive like most people are
in their own ways, I get there and I'm freaking
out.
I have to do, I have to get results, I have
to get images.
How am I gonna catch up?
Totally intimidated but I'm fired up, the
next morning I'm going to get gold images,
it's gonna be amazing.
The situation; I am a portrait photographer
and there are no people in Tasmania.
[Laughter]
>>Catherine Hall: I'm driving around looking
for people and they are not there.
It is so sparsely populated.
Oh, by the way, did I mention all the other
iconic photographers were like landscape photographers,
adventure photographers, like all the things
that are perfect for Tasmania?
[Laughter]
>>Catherine Hall: So what am I gonna do?
So I knocked and I knocked and I knocked.
Can any of you guys guess what I was doing?
Come on, somebody?
>>audience member: Going door to door?
>>Catherine Hall: Going door to door, baby.
[Laughs]
>>Catherine Hall: That's what I did.
I just started knocking on people's doors
and asking them if I could photograph them
cause that was the only way I could find people.
The interesting thing about it is this actually
became a huge advantage.
Not only was I able to photograph people but
I was able to photograph them in their own
environment.
So this is this guy, he was hilarious, he
was in his 80, ugh, I don't know in his 80's
or 90's but I asked him if he had any, a wife
or someone that he lived with.
And he's like, "Oh no, I can't settle down
with just one lady."
[Laughter]
>>Catherine Hall: This was the back, so coal
mining is really, it actually reminds me a
lot of Tasmania, I mean Appalachia in the
sense that there's a lot of areas that there's
a lot of coal mining that no longer exists.
So you have the people that used to have jobs
no longer having jobs.
And this was an old train rusting in the back,
this was a little girl believe it or not,
not a little boy and that was just in their
back yard.
This is a great story, so toward the end of
the trip it actually became kind of a joke
that I was the one going around knocking on
all these doors.
And I had a guide and our last day he said,
"Let's play a game."
And I said, "Alright, I'm up for a challenge,
what do you have for me?"
He said, "I'm gonna find the scariest house
and dare you to knock on the door."
So I mentioned to you that Tasmania's like
Appalachia, it's like the Wild West even though
Appalachia's not west, but point being that
it's crazy.
There's like do not enter, gun signs, like
it's not somewhere, there's like dogs beware,
private property, completely littered with
signs.
So we pull up to this house and he's like,
"Alright, here you go."
[Laughs]
>>Catherine Hall: I look at him and I think,
"Ugh, alright."
And what I found interesting enough was the
weirder the house was the nicer the people.
[Laughter]
>>Catherine Hall: So I went and knocked on
the door and sure enough it was this family
and they invited me inside and I hung out
with them and they, eventually we went outside
and I asked the kid, he was 4 by the way,
"Anvill can you show me your favorite toy?"
[Laughter]
>>Catherine Hall: He pulls out a frickin'
chainsaw.
[Laughter]
>>Catherine Hall: And the thing was that this
was a real chainsaw, this is not a toy.
It is heavy.
And what amazed me most is look at how he's
holding it with such ease.
This was seriously his favorite toy.
So I have to warn you though, if anyone's
gonna go out there and do this, it doesn't
always turn out so well.
[Laughter]
>>Catherine Hall: Yeah, that's why I don't
like photographing in Asian cultures cause
there's all dogs everywhere and they come
bite at you.
Anyway, the result is the images got lots
of rewards, they were published, had incredible
experiences.
One of the best things was because I came
a week late I was supposed to be on my own,
everyone else was leaving but I wanted to
stay an additional week past everyone and
I was supposed to be on my own Tourism Tasmania
actually funded the rest of my trip because
they were really interested in the images
that I was getting and they were unique.
So a lot of really wonderful things came out
of this.
So the lesson being, do not be limited by
your resources and do not be limited by apparent
resources.
And what I mean by that is it would have been
really easy just to say, "You know what, there's
not a lot of people in Tasmania I guess I'll
just shoot landscape or I'll shoot devils
or, you know, Tasmanian devils, but instead
it was kind of coming
[Laughs]
>>Catherine Hall: coming to the conclusion
that no, I am a portrait photographer, that
is what I excel at, how can I make this work?
So there's a show out there called 9 by Design,
have any of you guys seen it by any chance?
It's a design show on the, it was on the Bravo
network now it's on HGTV and it's this family,
they're incredible designers.
They live in Manhattan they basically take
buildings and completely renovate them.
So, for example, the last home they created
was a sex shop and they just completely tore
it out and renovated it and built a 20 million
dollar home right in New York.
So watching this TV show, and I'm not this
type of person like I don't like fall in love
with stars, but there's something about this
family that I really, really liked.
And I kind of fall in love with this family
watching their show and I kept thinking, "How
cool would it be to photograph this family?"
So, the situation is, I've fallen in love
with them, I see great potential, not only
photographing their family and their kids
because I am interested in them but also they're
designers, they do Tyra Banks' house, Trump's
house, like they have a lot of contacts.
And they love photography so I think, "Wow,
I can tap into their clientele and become
a referral from them.
So the only problem is I live 3,000 miles
away, I have no contacts, they have no contact
information listed and I don't really have
a family portfolio to show them.
One would think, "Good luck" right?
But I wrote a pitch letter anyway.
I labored over the pitch letter, sent it on
a Friday and honestly had zero expectations.
I sent it to their agent cause that was the
only contact I get, sent it to a New York
agent expecting nothing.
Monday morning I got a call from their agent
and she said, "they've gotten a ton of requests,
you're the first person that they're gonna
invite into their home."
I mean they'd had journalists come in but
never a photographer come in and stay with
them.
I lived with them for 3 days.
And these are some of the images I got.
So this is their family bathtub and this is
their two twin sons and their baby son.
This is their son Breaker, he's the cool one.
This is Breaker and their nanny, so they have
I think 5 or 6 nannies cause they have 7 kids.
But their nanny, you can see their relationship,
they're really, really part of the family.
This is Robert talking, sitting on his desk,
there's two desks like this in the entire
world.
One is in the Museum of Modern Art and the
other one's in his bedroom.
[Laughter]
>>Catherine Hall: This is their teenage daughter,
Bellamy, and I really wanted to play on, she's
12 and she's entering that really complex
age.
This is their gym in their basement, their
son's really into basketball.
This is their daughter Tallulah; this is the
view right outside their house.
So, the point of the story is this is that,
first off, this is one of the most rewarding,
fun weekends or 3 days of my life.
I had so much fun, this family is so special
and photographing them was so inspiring.
They also invited me back to be recorded on
their show.
So they're featuring me on their show which
is coming out in June and now I'm their family
photographer, they want me to come to Brazil
to photograph them and I'm building this portfolio.
There's a lot, this is just the beginning
too, I know a lot of other amazing things
are gonna come out of this.
So I really wanted to share this to you because
I think it's really easy to say something
won't work without trying.
Cause from an outsider, if somebody told me
the situation that I was going into writing
that pitch letter, most people would say that's
a waste of your time.
So don't dismiss it until you try it.
This is another shoot.
I did this shoot as a test shoot when I was
in New York and I was really inspired by it.
And I came to San Francisco and I thought
I'd love to do this old Hollywood San Francisco
shoot.
I kept waiting for like a client or a project,
something to come to me and then I realized
it wasn't gonna happen, no one was gonna share
the vision that I had and if I really wanted
to do this shoot I had to do it on my own.
So I spent several months putting together
a team and finding a venue.
And these are just a few of the people that
I pulled together and we created this really
inspiring, wonderful shoot.
And a lot of times I have no idea what I'm
gonna do with the images.
And that's okay.
If you have an idea, just go for it.
So have any of you ever been to the Julia
Morgan Ballroom in San Francisco?
It's like; it's magnificent, really beautiful.
So obviously I got a lot of satisfaction from
the shoot and it was my first experience really
producing a shoot and how much work went into
it and got a better understanding of the industry
through it.
And I also pulled together this team and made
a lot of contacts and still work with them
today.
And the images got published, won awards and
so a lot of great things happened afterwards
but that wasn't my impetus for doing it.
My impetus for doing it was cause I had an
idea and I had a sort of, we go back to intuition,
I knew it was something I needed to do.
So the lesson is if you're passionate about
an idea you're the only one who can really
make it happen.
Which brings us to personal projects, I have
a show that Ricardo mentioned, it's called
Twit Photo and we interview these exceptional
photographers every week.
And there's one common thread between all
of them which is great because this common
thread connects you professionals to you guys,
amateurs, enthusiasts, aspiring pros, not
aspiring pros cause you work at Google but
point being people that love photography,
it's all the same.
And what every single photographer says is
that you have to have personal projects.
So these are just a couple of the projects
that I've done where it's just been, this
is Burning Man, you've heard of Burning Man.
Has anyone gone to Burning Man?
Alright, one person, we're connected.
[Laughs]
>>Catherine Hall: So these are just a few
of the images I've gotten.
I've gone there about 4 or 5 years and that's
the thing that's great about personal projects
is that they can last as long or as short
as you want them to.
So if you're inspired by something you just
keep going back, you keep working on it.
And then, like I said, we don't plan for these
things but things come out of it later.
Whether it's getting you on magazines or winning
awards, here's a little exhibit that I did,
so if anyone wants to know what Burning Man's
like this gives you kind of a brief.
[Music plays]
[Laughs]
>>Catherine Hall: Yeah, that's what it's like,
it's kind of crazy.
[Music plays]
>>Catherine Hall: But we did a full on exhibit
with metal prints, Bay Photo sponsored it
and it was a day time and a night time exhibit.
[Music plays]
>>Catherine Hall: Does anyone wanna go?
[Laughs]
>>Catherine Hall: It's pretty cool, photographically
actually, that's the reason I went is I wanted
to photograph it and it's very cool for taking
photographs.
There's a lot of interesting art projects,
people, tons of stuff to photograph.
So the lesson is every great photographer
will explore their passions through personal
projects.
Alright, so we've talked a lot about the importance
of creating your own opportunities and doing
work that you love and following your intuition.
So, what do you guys think is the number one
reason that people don't pursue their passion
and just make it happen?
Come on, anyone?
>>audience members: [inaudible]
>>Catherine Hall: Time.
Money.
>>audience members: [Inaudible]
>>Catherine Hall: What?
>>audience members: They think more than act.
>>Catherine Hall: They think more than act.
That's a good one, big talker, no action.
>>audience members: Fear.
>>Catherine Hall: AH!
Fear, four people said it at once.
You guys are all awesome.
Everything you guys just said is totally right
but it all leads to fear.
It all leads to fear; money, I started doing
travel photography when I was in college.
I had to go to Asia cause that was the only
place I could afford.
You know, every single thing I hear, it all
comes back to fear.
What is the definition of fear?
It is a distressing emotion aroused by impending
danger, pain, etcetera, whether the threat
is real or imagined.
I think the key here is the threat is real
or imagined.
We all know that fear is good, right?
If the threat is real you need to react.
Unfortunately, emotionally fear is not real,
it is imagined, so it becomes real to you.
I actually, interestingly enough, I see fear
often as a sign of something I need to do.
If I get that feeling like, "Oh I don't wanna
do this" and I start making excuses.
"Ah, I don't have enough money, I don't have
enough time, I don't have this, this ,this."
It all comes back to fear.
So here's a couple things where I think fear,
overcoming your fear can help you as a photographer.
So number one, don't be afraid to make fun
of yourself or laugh at yourself.
If you photograph people, in particular, if
you're really serious looking through the
camera then they're gonna be a little intimidated.
If you're loose and you're having fun and
you're engaged, and I'm not saying you have
to be different than who you are as a human
being, but what I am saying is don't be too
uptight.
Especially when you're working with children,
allow yourself to come to their level, allow
yourself to act like an idiot.
Being an exceptional artist and playing safe
don't co-exist.
If you're gonna really excel at something
you can't do it by playing safe.
So I wanna tell you guys a little story about
Connor who's one and half years old.
I met him at Burning Man.
I photographed him in front of his grandfather's
trailer.
When it's time to process the photos I wanted
to do something kind of complex and kind of
dark.
I wanted to do something that was different
but it was risky.
And when I was done with this image I did
not want to share it with his father.
I did not minimize the dark circles under
his eyes, I accentuated them.
I did not minimize the dirt and dust all over
him, I pulled it out.
And this image at the exhibit I did was the
most controversial image there.
Half the people looked at it and, this was
the most conversation, this actually promoted
the most conversation as well, half the people
looked at it and thought, "Oh my gosh that's
so cool.
This kid is at Burning Man, he's dirty, this
is what kids are supposed to be like."
And the other half of the people are like,
"you shouldn't really bring kids to Burning
Man.
It's not good for him to breathe in this alkaline
dust."
So it really created a lot of conversation
and I was very, very scared for his father
to see this image.
Interestingly enough he loves it.
He called me, he wants prints, he wants the
file, he wants to do this that and the other.
He's so excited.
This is the best photograph he's ever seen
of his kid.
Tallulah, she's the daughter of the Novogratz
family in New York that I photograph that
I talked about, that have the show.
Tallulah is 12.
You know what it's like when you're 12.
You're going through all of these changes
and you're figuring out who you are.
She's twins with Bellamy who I showed you
in the slideshow, they're as opposite as can
be.
So when it was time to photograph Tallulah,
I was trying to figure out, you know, who
she is as a person.
She's very complex, she's very smart, she's
got kind of a dark side, how am I gonna show
this in this image?
[Pause]
>>Catherine Hall: So I put together this image
and I photographed it, I processed it and
I was, once again, horrified, like really
scared to share the image with the family.
They loved it cause that's their daughter.
So don't make judgments on what you think
people will think.
Don't play it safe when you have no idea what
others perceptions are.
You're making decisions on your own perception
which is not real and which is not right.
So fear is a little darkroom where negatives
are developed.
And that's the one thing I really want you
guys to walk away with.
When it comes to your photography don't forget
this lesson.
Yes?
>>male #1: [inaudible]
>>Catherine Hall: So his question was most
of my portraits are outdoors and do I control
light or do I shoot with natural light.
I started off exclusively shooting with natural
light.
And now I will travel with a reflector.
And I recommend California Sunbounce, they
make beautiful reflectors.
You do not need to carry around huge equipment
while you're shooting in these remote locations.
You can and I do sometimes cause I see value
to it but you can do a lot with a reflector.
The other thing is don't be afraid, it's good
to use shade, you know, so you can shoot any
time of the day.
But if you have a reflector you'll at least
get pop and contrast and color and the main
thing is you really wanna make sure that their
eyes are not dark sockets.
So you stick someone in the shade and don't
use any reflectors, a lot of times their eyes
will just kind of go black and lifeless and
you really wanna avoid that.
So if you are using a reflector make sure
you're at least getting a little, what we
call, a ping in the eye.
Does that help?
Yeah?
>>male #2: You don't seem to be a big fan
of smiling faces.
>>Catherine Hall: Oh, great question.
So he says I'm not a huge fan of smiling faces.
And actually that's a great observation.
The first thing I tell people when I shoot
them is, when I shoot them
[Makes shooting noise]
>>Catherine Hall: is do not smile.
I don't want you to smile.
If I make you laugh then laugh, if you're
feeling like smiling then naturally smile
because I'm doing something silly.
But I'm controlling them in a sense, I'm telling
them what to feel.
So if I act crazy silly I want them to laugh;
it will be real, it will be authentic.
But the main point of the story is I don't
want people doing any expressions that are
not real.
So I guess the moral of the story is that
I don't like people smiling.
[Laughter]
>>Catherine Hall: Yes?
>>male #3: How do you do focusing?
>>Catherine Hall: How do I do focusing?
So, that's actually a really good question,
I had other tips but we don't have time to
get through them.
One thing, I use auto focus for everything.
And the one thing I learned is the center
point, especially if you're using really fast
lenses like the 85 1.2, the center point is
the best focus point.
It's the fastest one.
So if you're ever having a problem focusing
your lens by using, you know, you can change
like if you have a side point, put it to the
center cause that's the only way I can focus
with an 85.
Does that answer?
>>male #3: Yeah, I had the same problem with
an 85 focusing.
>>Catherine Hall: Yeah, it's the only way
to do it.
Do, I'll get it focused on the center point
and then I'll recompose.
Cause I'm never, my subjects never in the
center or very, very rarely in the center
so it's kind of like a dance, focus, compose,
focus, compose, but that's the only way it
works with really fast lenses like the 85.
Or, actually, the slow lenses if you will.
Yeah?
>>male #4:But there is curvature of field
and if you do that then you can't focus.
>>Catherine Hall: Yeah, so he just had a great
observation.
He said that there's curvature of field and
if you do that by the time, it's not gonna
be optimal.
When shooting portraits it's so negligible
that it really doesn't matter for me.
If I was shooting something like architecture
that was gonna be blown up to a huge billboard
then I would be more concerned about that
and I would manually focus at that time.
So if your goal is to have the sharpest focus
and you're shooting something that you want
depth, great depth of field, and you have
the time to manually focus, then manually
focus, but with people they're moving, I'm
not gonna do anything huge with the files,
I don't think it really matters so much, but
that's a good observation.
Yeah, oh sorry did you, he was holding for
awhile, yeah?
>>male #5: Do you get model releases for all
of your photos [inaudible].
>>Catherine Hall: Yeah, I'm so glad you asked
that.
He asked if I get model releases and this,
I can't even tell you how important it is
to get model releases.
When I first started my career I was in college,
I was just traveling around taking photos
and I wasn't getting model releases cause
I figured, I'm not doing anything with these
I'm just building a portfolio.
And it's really easy to do this and this goes
back to fear cause it sucks getting a model
release, doesn't it?
It's not fun.
So I made an excuse and didn't get them.
And then Adobe asked me and then I started
getting recognition for my work and Adobe
wanted to do something with my images and
I had no images cause none of them had model
releases.
So the moral of the story is, I think it's
very, very, very important to get releases,
I think also you do not need to use intimidating
language.
So like the Getty releases and a lot of them
have this crazy legal language, it's actually
legally better to have a simple release that
just says Catherine Hall can use, and I'm
coming out with a model release app by the
way.
[Laughs]
>>Catherine Hall: It's been submitted to the
Apple store.
But it's called Top Model Release and actually
using a device even makes it less intimidating
somehow and it's really, really easy to get
model releases that way and organize them.
But you can create custom releases and my
release is literally, "Catherine Hall photographed
me on May 16th, 2012.
She has permission to use the images in any
purpose in any form."
Period.
Versus like she can distort my face and da,
da, da, da, da.
Cause you don't really, in a lot of ways it
makes it actually less legal when you have
those really convoluted long releases.
Yeah?
>>Catherine Hall: Yeah, he's asking about
models asking about consideration.
Asking for money, asking for, and I think
that really depends on the individual.
When I photograph people it's, I'm giving
a lot too.
It's kind of, we're building a relationship
and they're as invested as I am.
When I'm going into these people's homes I'm
giving them prints.
So if you're traveling a lot I recommend carrying
a Polaroid so you can give someone the print
automatically cause otherwise you have to
send it and it takes long and you don't wanna
do it.
But if you can give them something right away
that's great.
But what I found is as soon as you start negotiating
money, especially before you start shooting,
then it sort of taints the relationship.
Cause then all of a sudden it's not about
an experience anymore.
It's about them hiring, being hired for a
job.
However, in the past, what I have done if
I've seen someone being really needy or a
family being needy, I've gone through the
whole thing with no expectation of money and
then at the end given them something as like
a token of my appreciation.
But I've had people ask me for money right
out of the gate and I'll actually avoid photographing
those people because I know their intentions
not pure.
And usually those people are the ones that'll
be like, "Alright, you get one shot."
And then you wanna take more and they want
more money and it's just not a very good experience
for anyone.
And the photographs don't feel authentic and
real.
>>Catherine Hall: So he's asking basically
how often, what proportion do I feel the images
can be kept natural or do I need to go in
and retouch.
I think this is very, very subjective and
I like images on both extremes from other
photographers.
For me, personally, I like bringing out, I'm
trying to tell a story with every single image
so I use Photoshop as a tool to illustrate
that message of that story.
So, for example, the boy with the dust all
over him, if I hadn't retouched the dust to
really come out it wouldn't, it would feel
a little flat.
So I wanted to accentuate, yes he was dirty,
he was at Burning Man, it was crazy, it was
hot, you know?
So I want that story and I use the retouching
as a way of sort of making sure that message
is given to the viewer easily.
>>male #6: My question is do you actually
see them
>>Catherine Hall: Oh, do I see them retouched
or do I see them
>>male #6: Yeah when you take the picture
do you see them
>>Catherine Hall: That's a really, really
great question.
He's asking if I see it in advance or if it's
something I do during post, come up with a,
I definitely do not see it retouched.
Some people will, they will shoot it knowing
how it's gonna end up.
For me, I'm very organic with the way I shoot
and I'm not, I'm just thinking about getting
the best I can in camera and that's, my focus
is on that.
So the lighting, the composition, all these
different factors and then when I pull in
the image I think, alright, that's when the
second tier of the creative process starts.
Is where do I wanna take this with the retouching?
>>Presenter: Alright, well thanks everybody
for coming out tonight and thank you Catherine.
>>Catherine Hall: Thank you guys so much.
[Applause]